un pueblo de 10.000 habitantes en los
que han muerto por el terremoto entre
253 300 personas un porcentaje enorme se
trata del pueblo de bellogg en la
provincia de cangra más calamán marassa
que fue el epicentro del terremoto que
ocurrió en la madrugada del domingo al
lunes de esta semana los vecinos de ese
pueblo nos explican desde pequeño pueblo
nos explican que los servicios de
rescate nunca han venido aquí han pasado
de largo directamente hacia la ciudad y
a las grandes ciudades donde Sí hay
equipos de rescate aquí sin embargo nos
cuentan que todos los muertos han tenido
que ser rescatados por los propios
vecinos todos los con los que hemos
hablado han dicho que ellos mismos
participaron con sus propias manos para
intentar rescatar o vivos o muertos los
cuerpos de sus vecinos en los últimos
días sí que explican que ha empezado a
llegar algo de ayuda humanitaria mantas
agua comida pan y té caliente sin
embargo aseguran que tienen muchísimos
problemas sobre todo higiénicos de agua
corriente y para ir al baño
si no reciben ayuda inmediata y con
orden nos dicen que Hasta ahora ha
llegado sin orden podrían salir muchos
problemas de salud derivados del
maltratamiento de las aguas fecales y de
los restos de las personas que aquí
mismo viven en tiendas algunas
proporcionadas por el gobierno Turco
otros hechos por los propios habitantes
de este lugar